[Musique]
on a notre famille qui est en Iran on
voit à quel point il souffre qu'on a eu
la chance d'y aller pratiquement tous
les étés et de voir de nous-même de
vivre cette oppression et du coup on
pense que c'est c'est le moment pour une
fois les femmes se soulèvent elles sont
accompagnées des hommes c'est vraiment
le moment de d'essayer de changer les
choses et eux ils sortent mais ils se
font tuer nous on a la chance de pouvoir
manifester et se battre pour eux
[Musique]
notre rôle c'est d'aide la voix des gens
à l'intérieur on porte leurs doigts on
porte leur demande on veut que le monde
entier sache qu'est-ce qui se passe en
Iran et quels sont leurs revendications
[Musique]